AMC's The Walking Dead has become a
staple of Sunday television endlessly
shocking and delighting fans with its
gory action and non-stop drama but grim
apocalyptic series has gotten
increasingly violent over the years to
the point of some fans have even called
it quits because of the alarming
brutality while others have become urged
by some key changes from the original
comic scenes but even those who have
stuck around from the start
still might be surprised to find out
these facts about the series he is what
you may not know about The Walking Dead
taking the lead in a major case of
Hollywood sliding doors Andrew Lincoln
almost wasn't cast as Sheriff Rick
Grimes because he accepted a role in
another film at the time but life got in
the way his second child was born
shortly before the film was expected to
commence production so Lincoln decided
against shooting it after all he told
The Hollywood Reporter I got a friend to
replace me in this movie and the next
day the script came through from AMC I
must have been on the radar with Frank
and he wanted me to test it was
incredible what got him to agree to take
the audition to begin with he later
revealed was the fact that executive
producer and show co-creator Frank
Darabont was involved he believed that
meant the show could have a real future
that made moving his growing family
worth it as he told Rolling Stone Frank
talked us into getting on that plane
what steam swarm during production on
the second episode of the inaugural
season The Walking Dead's cast and crew
got an unexpected set two visitors a
SWAT team male actor Michael Rooker was
on a rooftop shooting his rifle -
simulator zombies my possession but
unluckily took his behavior for the real
deal and called in the cops
I saw people jumped in run they'd
already dispatched the SWAT team the
officer of him please stand down and won
the last time a false alarm would ring
regarding the show in 2016 a Great Falls
Montana family have found themselves
swarmed by police after neighbors called
in a possible domestic violence incident
involving guns inside their home because
they were watching the show loud enough
for neighbors to think a big shootout
was going down pulling Frank's
for a show with such grisly material as
The Walking Dead it stars ashore know
how to have fun when the cameras aren't
rolling actor Norman Reedus in
particular has a longer running history
of pranking Andrew Lincoln and others
during production some of his greatest
hits from the thick history book of
their prank wars include readers filling
Lincoln's car vents with glitter so that
had exploded all over him as soon as he
cranked the AC then there was the time
he told Lincoln to greet Japanese fans
of the phrase or where's the toilet when
he wanted to say thank you for allowing
me to be here Lincoln's been known to
get him back on occasion - like when he
put readers his treasured motorcycle on
a boat with a sex doll and a scented
sailing to the middle of a lake but the
best is when he gets more precise forms
of payback
[Applause]
JMC Easter eggs The Walking Dead is an
Easter egg lovers dream because the show
is filled with hidden tributes to the
original comics other zombie epics and
the plenty more AMC's her sister head
Breaking Bad receive some of the most
clever winks and references for instance
there was a Heisenberg blue mass that
appeared in a bag of drugs it showed in
the second season and let's not forget
when daryl dixon basically described his
brothers dealer and the Jesse Pinkman
fits the description to a tee
mahadji Speer Genki or what I should not
kill you [ __ ] the connections have been
significant enough to even inspire some
theorists to connect the timeline of the
two shows and deposit a cause and effect
relationship between Walter White's
chemical concoction and the onset of the
zombie plague yeah mr. white yes science
hey anything's possible The Walking Dead
has still yet to explain where and why
the Walker infection happened
lurking the neighbors you might think
living in a small town where one of TV's
biggest hits has made would be a treat
but for some residents of Senoia Georgia
the experience of becoming a mini
Hollywood has been unpleasant at times
as reported by ABC News some of the
neues natives have been annoyed by being
asked to change their activities in
their hometown as a result of its
proximity to the set from taking
pictures to trimming trees show
officials have stepped in to moderate
what would otherwise be considered
pretty ordinary behaviors and they come
out of there and I needed to stop their
filming I said well no he just carry
your happy but right behind the wall set
attention has also spawned an army of
Walker stalkers that is fans who case
the town in hopes of catching a glimpse
which is both a business boon and
headache for locals especially when
explosive scenes are being shot nearby
one of the neighborhoods to compensate
for the troubles though some families
are paid a monthly stipend of $400 and
others have received in person thanks
from some of the cast earning outrage
well plenty of devastating character
deaths have happened on the Walking Dead
the years one killing in particular had
commentator's in a tizzy in the sixth
season Merritt Weaver's dr. Denise Lloyd
was killed off and it wasn't just the
fact that she died in a way that in the
comics happened to Abraham instead it
was the fact that her death added to a
growing trend of that season in which
lesbian characters were routinely and
and ceremoniously executed on various
shows the show was immediately panned
after the episode aired for playing into
the berry' your gaze trope that seems to
be so common in mainstream television in
2016 of the controversy Weaver herself
told The Daily Beast I haven't thought
about it that way I'm not sure that
that's what was going on here but they
understand the sentiment very well
avoiding the amputation one of the most
glaring omissions from The Walking
Dead's transformation from book to
screen has been the fact that Rick's
still got both of his hands in the
comics the governor cuts off Rick's
right hand his shoot aside no less so
when the governor arrived on screen in
the third season many readers were
braced for the inevitable but it never
happened there have been a couple minor
wings to the event like merle a
character unique to the show having to
cut off his own hand to escape being
handcuffed to a rooftop and then there
was the time that villainous negan the
threatened to cut off Cole's hand in the
seventh season but Rick's still working
with two fully functional fists so what
gives in his reddit AMA series the comic
books co creator Robert Kirkman explains
the decision as a matter of practicality
saying to clarify I think a cutting
Rick's hand off when we did was great
for the comic it's just that in another
medium it would be harder to pull off we
cheat in the comic because things aren't
moving you can't do that on the show
you'd see Rick not being able to reload
his gun and things like that the CGI of
cutting off Rick's hand would be
expensive but we did it with Herschel's
leg so if we felt strongly about Rick
losing a hand with do it optimistic end
game the show may have diverged from
writer Robert Kirkman's ongoing comic
series in some significant ways but he
still has a lot of creative influence on
the walking dead production according to
him fans can expect the ending to both
versions to be hopeful he said it's a
very popular show and the
executives at AMC seemed to wanted to go
for 50 seasons and it may go for 50
seasons but there is definitely an end
point at some point I see the story from
beginning to end over many many years so
I think it's a very hopeful story about
humanity overcoming this insurmountable
apocalyptic situation it's just going to
take them a long time to do it but until
then we all just enjoy the grim ride
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Applause]